hello my name is mathias from data and
in this video i want to show you
you can easily calculate a linear
regression beta tab online you can do
this first of all on the
tde click on the statistics calculator
and since we want to calculate a recession
we click on
repression
then if you want to use your own
data first you
learned the table now you can
simply copy your own data in here
i have prepared a small example
so i just want the witch
the data from tone c and copy
the actions in the table in  this
example of simply driving a person according to their
weight, height, age and gender
so now we
can start calculating the recession right away
in this example we want to know whether
weight is dependent on
height, age and gender
, i.e. the weight is  our
dependent variable and height
age and  gender is the independent
variable so that we can now calculate the recession
we first
have to form the dependent variable
said we want
weight to be the dependent variable and
here we can then calculate the
independent variables height age and
gender from now calculated
and state  app the linear regression for
the data an upper table gives
state app the determined heizwerk
square and the adjusted determination
marsberg square and in the second
table we see the whole model is
significant or not
in this case because the sigma is
less than 0  .05 is the model
significant in the last table
we now get the diffusion coefficients
for our model once the and
standardized crosby coefficients
and the standardized percent
peter for size age and
male finally we see the
significant so whether the patients are
significant it will not change anything on
en  on the right side we can see the
scatter diagram where we can already
read off the dependencies graphically
if you have the premium version
you can simply click here to
check suspensions and you will receive an
evaluation of whether the prerequisites
for the linear regression are met
or not  not if you have an independent
variable that has more than two
expressions, gender
now has two expressions in that case, if you
escalated a nominal one that
has more than at expression, then the
offender type automatically created tami
variables so that it can also
simply have one  region so
I hope you liked the video
if you have any questions just leave us
a comment thank you